[Bollywood music playing]
Cut!
Okay, everyone
[bell ringing]
that was good.
[applause]
But we can do 10 percent better.
[applause and cheering]
That was beautiful.
-Okay.
Very, very good.
Ahhh!
My friends from college
are here.
Boss!
Perfect timing!
Welcome to the set of
I'm playing you!
You like the costume?
We need to talk.
Tell the director
I have some notes for him.
-We need to talk to you
in private.
Oh, Karun, he's worked with me
for 50 years.
I trust him completely.
Actually, when we first met,
he thought I was a vampire.
And he tried to
stake me through the heart.
I have apologized
so many times.
Not quite enough times.
Very close though.
I'll let you know.
Oh, I have to get ready
for the next scene.
Come to my tent.
We'll talk there.
You guys are gonna love
the next scene.
I come in
on a wire,
'cause you know
I can't fly.
Wait.
Are we getting
back together?
We need to talk.
The Deviants are back.
We don't know
how many there are.
You need to come with us.